all right hello
hell yeah where'd you go where are you
from originally i was born in the azores
in portugal
and where'd you grow up i was brought up
in lowell massachusetts and
tell me about your childhood you had
both your parents as a kid um
i was brought up by my grandmother
grandfather
until i was seven and from seven
to sixteen i stayed with my parents and
got pregnant
went on my own um
stayed in massachusetts until my son was
nine and
been out here the rest of the time
[Music]
now he's grown up and
i've been out here for 21 years and
didn't even call my
family for 20 years i thought i was dead
and just time goes by really fast when
you're
not doing right and the number one
reason why
you know homeless people don't contact
their family it's because of shame
and it was so wrong my grandparents were
dead
and my mom and dad they were in their
late 80s
they just went back to portugal they
came and visited me um
i have five sisters i'm the oldest
and it feels good to have a family after
so long
so you're still in touch with everybody
everyone yeah i just talked to my
sisters we all get together um on the
phone
and they were coming to visit me until
this corona sickness now they just stay
in the house
what is your drug today i uh smoke crack
and you've been doing that since when
since i was
17. how did you first get turned down to
crack
i started doing um lines of
powder cocaine back east we started
cooking it was freebasing
and now it's just fake
fake stuff that everybody's addicted to
but they're not really getting high it's
not funny anymore
it's uh maintenance um
back east we used to go camping over
here it's called survival
and they used to call us white chili
trash and now i say trailer trash
wannabes
i would love to have my big trailer we
used to go camping
i could live there all year long
now but um i just got to get myself
together and go to rehab and
start all over so your son is how old
now
my son was born in 1987.
he's 33.
and you you raised him for part of his
life uh until he was nine
and that's when the drugs kind of took
hold yeah um
his dad um kept him home from school
and then the state came in and he was
drinking and
drug paraphernalia he left this
brazilian lady in
and after that
i couldn't leave the dad so but i was
working and i could pass a drug test but
his dad couldn't so
um they were about to take my son so i
called debbie his aunt and
she took temporary custody of him
and she brought him up right he went to
college and
um i'm
like 75 sure that if i would have
brought him out here with me he'd
end up on the streets um
and being with her he went to college he
doesn't do drugs he drinks now because
dad died two years ago but
um still a truck driver
drives an 18 wheeler and um i'm proud i
mean i talked to him on the phone now
and it's just good to have family back
yeah it's good that he's not living on
the streets here yeah yeah yeah he's
he's smart you know he's going to work
and
i'm just glad that i mean i missed him
all these years and stuff but
i'm glad that he was brought up right
how do you support yourself living here
i am
i got food stamps ga um
hustling streets um
shoplifting um mostly i do um
distraction like i'll go in and knock
down shelves and
you know my friends get to um
it's not right but um
it is what it is what do you think
people that don't do drugs
that watch these kind of videos watch
these stories don't understand about
addiction
yeah they don't unless you've been there
you you have no idea
it's just sad you know i tell the kids
i say go to school do your homework
listen to your parents
don't drink don't do drugs go to college
get degrees
don't end up like these people sleeping
on the street and
i just hope that maybe just 5 out of 100
make it to college just because they
heard hey i heard that crazy lady saying
you know but um yeah if
if you just live right and go to college
and get a degree
and don't do drugs you gotta make you
know but um
if you don't you fall into
alcohol and drugs it's pretty much
takes a lot of years out of your life
how do you think this this lifestyle has
changed you over the years
well um
made me numb like i drink and do drugs
just to become numb
uh it made me um tougher like i'm
pretty much fearless you know like i'll
go out there to
three o'clock in the morning just like
in the middle of the afternoon
and somebody like me shouldn't really be
out there with all the
car creatures i call them um
but
i am i consider myself pretty
street smart which is nothing to be
proud about but um
you learn how to survive and you learn
who the
gang members are and you learn who
like the og's the top guys and you learn
how they are
and who they are and then you start
hanging with them and
you're pretty much protected like
because they'll say don't
mess with her she's like one of us but i
don't belong to no gang i'm just me
i'm one team
what would you say to a young person
who's considering going down this kind
of path
oh man i i just i hate to see the girls
half my age
um you know
just don't do it don't
fall because once you fall it's hard to
get up um
but i see a lot of them uh walking with
you know like i know where they're going
who they're going with what they're
going to do
and how they're going to feel afterwards
but i really can't do nothing about it
because
um i have to walk around in the streets
so
it's sad but a lot of times like i'll
say
your mom just paid me 50 to come get you
you got to come with me she's going to
give me another 50
and it's all just the lie just to get
them away from whoever they're with
um the other day um my little friend was
getting into a car
and it was undercover cop and right
before she got in i
grabbed her and i'm like you might want
to see it it would be and she was mad
but
you know once she um
knew that he was police then she loved
me
and i go around um saving these little
youngsters that smoking fentanyl
and they're just dying like flies i mean
like i walked by and there's these
little
kids turning blue and nobody's even i
mean like everybody's just walking by
and not even acknowledged it's just
another homeless people but
um it's somebody's son it's somebody's
daughter
and i carry uh my purse with
um narcan and
just last month i saved five of them and
it's funny because
uh after you save them you give them
this narcan they can't get high
for 72 hours so they get so mad
it's like [ __ ] you're mad at me for
saving your life
you know but they don't understand until
this one little girl she went to jail
and she had been there for six months
and then i ended up in there
and she's like oh boston i love you you
saved my life but like for the whole
time that she was on the street
she was mad and you don't really
realize until the smoke clears um
a lot of times when i go to jail three
four days
over the weekend and stuff the smoke
clears
and when i come out i go straight to the
woman's place and i want to go upstairs
to
you know rehab but they say um no
come back tomorrow and i know that if i
leave
i'll just smoke and then i won't be back
tomorrow but
i mean like the last three times they
actually had to call the police
and it was funny because the police you
know like i gave him a hard time
and you know i'm kind of wise when i
drink and
um police were like please please keep
her there and
uh just once i go up back out there it's
over
what's what's one of the most horrible
things you've seen down here in the
tenderloin
um pretty much my best friend getting
stabbed to death
and there was nothing i could do about
it um
and then police wanted me to tell on you
know the people
that stabbed him but
you know once you snitch on those guys
you pretty much
either have to leave or end up
dead so they wanted me to point them out
but half of them like went back to their
own country
and drug dealers and stuff and
it was pretty bad because after he
couldn't breathe anymore
i was in that circle and like i got weak
like oh my god
because they will kill you just so you
don't talk
and but i got strength and i just ran
and um after that it was pretty much
just um suffering
out it was my best friend and now he's
gone
but it is what it is
do you have regrets about any parts of
your life
yeah um
i wish i didn't keep my family
worried about me for 20 years but
there's nothing i can do about that now
but
i just make it up to them by um
visiting when they want to visit and
calling them all the time
and just keeping in touch that's all
they want
is for me to be all right
all right heather thank you so much for
talking with me and thank you
good luck with whatever you do next yeah
thanks
thank you wow
oh that was great
thank you speaker